Adam Smith talked about believe it or
not the free market what did he mean by
the free market the most classic uh way
to think of it is kind of free from the
state right wrong he meant free from
rent so Adam Smith is well in his Wealth
of Nations and David Ricardo and later
Carl Marx really looked at this notion
of rent and worried about what would
happen when the goods in the system the
profits being generated were siphoned
off they were living through the 1800s
Adam Smith a bit before that during the
Industrial re ution so instead of
looking at the fields terms of farm
labor being the source of value they
looked at factories and they were very
interested in the degree to which
profits being earned were in fact
reinvested to make these factories more
productive so the implication was if you
weren't reinvesting back into production
and kind of around organizational
Innovation technological innovation the
system itself would
rest